[Musique]
deux victoires m'appelle pour me dire
maman aussi les clés de chez victor
parce que il semblait endormi puis bon
je partis on a regardé par la fenêtre on
trouvait qu'il bougeait pas beaucoup il
lui disait on était un peu inquiet en
ouvrant la porte pire
le temps était couché dans son lit mam
est animé depuis plusieurs heures
probablement son ordinateur est ouvert
et c'est le choc j'ai cessé de me dire
mais victor pourquoi pourquoi victoire
twitter qu est ce qu est ce que tu te
fais je vois à côté du lit un espèce de
piché un pichet de jus de joubert
je me suis dit ça noté sa tisane
il y avait des projets elle avait des
portes ouvertes pour lui la met juste au
moment où ça arrive parfois qu'on
s'endort si on se réveille pour on
s'endort en écoutant les simpson
[Musique]
vite
il est arrivé beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup ces failles notre impressionné
tout le monde personne féminine
beaucoup beaucoup de tours réflexion au
fit travailler fort pour se sentir bien
et qui est en équilibre
plus tard à kaeslin est un meilleur ami
c'était un grand artiste un homme
complexe puis est un homme très
travailleur qu'il stoppe ma guen ne
vécurent sensée escaut técher groupe
france puis le symbole que ici c'est le
elle avec l'europe il es qui représente
peu partout qui sévit la hausse sauf qui
venu à créer près s'abriter fekter des
slaves sauf aux symboles bencini lead in
his band
[Musique]
vers l'été 2012 c'est là que les choses
ont commencé à déraper
on était des jeunes dans la vingtaine on
avait des vies actives
thunder bay friends of a victory qui vit
encore dextérité moment où il est sorti
de sa maison désintoxication victor
était sobre par choix n'était il voulait
pas prendre de drogue
il voulait pas retouché à des choses qui
lui causera une dépendance mais c'est là
qu'on a vu apparaître un peu le le
kratom dans sa ville cette plante l'eau
était on peut commercialiser comme et à
peut-être un alternative aux opioïdes
affaire me dire que mes prédictions déjà
dans certains patients à moi que j'ai vu
arriver dans mon bureau me dire de tamar
et je suis pris sur l'héroïne j'aimerais
m'en sortir avec le kratom donc on peut
faire un traitement de substitution avec
le kratom donc se tourner vers une
brûlure au créneau
le problème avec le kratom c'est quand
on dépasse des doses là on développe des
effets du type opioïdes comme on voit
avec la morphine le fatah l'île où les
ruines
[Musique]
moi je proposais la verveine la
camomille
mais les jeunes ont même saisi
s'amarrera calme ça m'apaise
j'ai l'esprit clair et variées de même à
100 dans les fêtes qui qu'ils soient
seront plus verte qui faisait pas bon de
nous expliquer ma femme actuelle ça fait
comme c'est un peu comme si ils nous
présenter ce commun le même genre de
boisson café
j'imagine qu'il y avait trouvé là une
balance parfaite et se croyait vraiment
avoir trouvé la formule parfaite pour
lui maintenant
malheureusement moi j'ai vu des gens
dans ma pratique aussi arriver dans mon
bureau m direct docteur je me suis
acheté du crac hommes pour mon trouble
d'attention sur moi ça me frise les
oreilles quand j'entends qu'on peut
l'utiliser qu'à temps pour le tibet ça
ça me préoccupe beaucoup parce qu'on
sait qu'il y en a beaucoup des gens qui
ont été déjà
[Musique]
concentration comme limite pds
les gardes
[Musique]
perdu
ouais
[Musique]
louise thibault et un sweat shirt loose
invictus dans ce cas tom est écrit dans
sa liste comme était écrit légumes cuits
qu est ce qu on voit ça faisait partie
des deux sens dessus dessous de son
cette idée là il marque fait attention
avec le 12 âge j'aurais avantage
accueilli les doses restantes
je crois qu'on parle du créateur
missiles uss vécu qu'un faux dj white
dude je les ai jamais vus 5 la tonne
dans les dernières années parce qu'ils
étaient toujours en proximité de seuil
il y avait clairement besoin de ça pour
pour fonctionner paris un petit creux la
soirée avançait puis e10 est vraiment
m'y avoir des tremblements qui était qui
était très très anormaux cité poste
c'était pas un tremblement de café le
thé vraiment loin de leurs victimes
voisine de wind waker
puis travaillé à force il y joua son
atelier qui était très concentré et tout
s'est mis à trembler comme s'ils avaient
fait une confusion et l'oeil on peut
tomber alors qu'on lui demande de rester
à l'hôpital
la victoire nous nous implore de les
chercher sa tisane le short pour les
internautes et à l'hôpital demain et le
vraiment à 3 heures du matin de retour
nation
on y retourne à son appartement ça
s'arrête entrées pour aller chercher sa
dose de tisanes pas ce que dit j'ai
besoin de ce domaine vient ne pourront
ne pas accrocher ou ne peut on n'a pas
dit ben voyons c'est pas bon ça me va
pas là comme on est comme aller chercher
cette zone c'est quand même ça m'étonne
encore
mais on plie pas fait ou non plus pareil
soyez pas droit à congés mais passez
vous que quand ce matin faisait de la
recherche la main était complet
[Musique]
on se borne à saïda
deux compagnies
[Musique]
de cambridge à ce titre à l'industrie
je comprends pas sur le sac de créateur
et écrit ce n'est pas pour la
consommation humaine
alors pour faire prendre pour qui ce
pour m pour faire chauffer si c'est pour
eux c'est pour ces pots fer de lance a
cessé pour donner à votre chien si si
mais ça rentre à plein à plein kg ha au
canada et s'est vendu
[Musique]
jean françois vincent et weizman 12 par
m
ap
[Musique]
et ce taux jean françois vincent
certains secteurs
[Musique]
pour qui sait
il est malin
ah oui aussi bas
ok jean françois vincent
[Musique]
ça devrait substances étudiées
réglementé étudié puis l'on en tire des
vraies conclusions mais en ce moment je
trouve que c'est vraiment la roulette
russe un petit peu le cas tombe
les gens se mettent le doigt dans
l'engrenage mais on sait pas comment ça
va finir
puis moi ce que je vais à date ça ça mal
fini parce que toutes les voix de
coinsins quest 2 victoires doivent
concourir idole avec ses tantes oncles
et des cousins
[Musique]
en
l'âge des français qui tragique est mort
en buvant l'ati dame se croyant l'abri
victims of earth stood at it like a dude
à nice d'eric besnard en date il y avait
de l'information qui marquait sur les
effets du crac sommes sur ce que ça
pouvait faire puis que cette information
le avait manqué à victor nous avait
manqué à nous à ce moment le puits
manqué peut pas être en ce moment à
maintenant
oh
telle est la question
foals
[Musique]
il voulait toujours play pu faire encore
plus plus beau puis faire encore mieux
comme sortis ils sont toujours à la
quête l'anxiété de performance et tout
ça et peut-être qu'ils arrachent du crac
hommes subtilement très subtilement
s'est installé pour calmer sa et au prix
de plus en plus d'ampleur a commencé à
détruire à lui couper de plus en plus
lisez jusqu'à jeu khalfa mourir
christophe résister à tout sauf ce mot
est important de la voir se battre parce
que si la pièce et le quai victor et je
sort qui serait serait d'accord avec
l'emplacement
[Musique]